chá lời của họ là tại sao?
Già cao
Già rất
mà cháu thì chưa hình
thì bắt buồn cả tiều phương
và tiến ra rất trất cao
Già rất là đồng vào
của tất cả các dưới án
và đồng vào của
nên kỳ đề
khi mà già cao thì tất cả các dưới phía nó sẽ chuyển thành
chưa nói là nha đủ tui còn phải
phải gôn
rồi là cái quy trình như là các đệ điều nói là sao
rất mà cái quy trình tụt được cảnh trình
mà kéo dài nữa
khi nó tất cả cái đếp tổng rồi
và bởi vì chi trình phía
mà
sạc vào của cùng tàn cáo như vậy
thì thì cái đả nha sẽ là cao thôi
thì nha nước tuo vào như thế giải trình tạng
thì già đồng vào cái già bàn
có thể tất cả cái chị kỳ đi càng
cho nên chúng ta ra quyết bình đẹn là giải quyết đồng vào
nha nước mới rời quyết định là
nha nước quyết định trên cửa sử dụng
và phương phát quả công khai mình bạch
có kích lối liền thông kỳ thì giữ liệu rất đại về cả tệ dưới dưới lụng
chuyến ngày hóc
thì ở đây là nha nước điều kiến
thì ra ra phải quảng như vậy cho họ còn li của nha nước
thì chúng ta mì vua chúng ta mì kiểm soát được
như thế giới phía đồng vào
kết hợp với đỏ là cái trụ thuộc khánh chính đơn giải
mình bạch thông khai
mình kể ra ra ra ra ra ra ra rộn
này và giúp ngảm lạc
thì quyết chính thuộc thuộc thuộc thuộc thuộc
với những tị
nynh pháp công đệ như vậy thì chúng ta mì làm vào được thế giới phía đồng vào
mà mình kìểm soát được lã nhá
là nó rất là đồng ra